and liftoff in many ways 2014 was all
about progress but it was also about the
past a very specific past the 1960s
without a push off that Castro
internationally our attention was
focused on countries like Russia Cuba
and North Korea was like the Berlin Wall
was still standing if Russia continues
to interfere in Ukraine we stand ready
to impose further sanctions home we were
concerned with civil rights 45 years
after the birth of the gay rights
movement at the Stonewall Inn gay
marriage became legal in a majority of
states that may pronounce you married
but when it came to race relations the
nation took a step backward no probable
cause exists to file any charge against
officer Wilson in a Gallup poll
fifty-seven percent of Americans
described race relations as fairly bad
to very bad other than during the LA
riots in 1992 that figure was the
highest it's been since the late 60s
even one of the taboos of the 60s was
revisited four states east declaring war
on marijuana and legalized them while 14
other states to criminalize them and
some of the same things that captivated
us decades ago did so again NASA sent
its Orion capsule deeper into space than
any time since the Apollo moon missions
systems are up and running in good shape
in this case NASA's goal is Mars but
still we gathered around to see if we
could explore someplace we've never been
before it was an oddly from
your field and a new era of American
space exploration